so why are you so selfish and I'm like
you know me well you call me selfish so
look you got so much to offer the world
why do you want to do this and and I
already done that right I wrote the
first book and when I wrote the first
book I started talking all over the
country I was doing some of the largest
events in America in 98 and then I saw
things I start doing a lot of religious
events to religious organizations and so
things that I didn't see in my world and
it really just jaded me what you mean
well you know I saw people be not what
there was what they were supposed to be
I saw big televangelist one day in a
studio where I was hosting a program
someone asked him for water he asked for
water and it gotta be some aggressing
just left off his hands says you know
better than to give me water in a glass
I take Perrier then unlike me I would
have kicked you out soap haha and and
and just different things you know
different things that that is yeah and
the division among them you know and in
the hatred and you know and it's like
look I don't care if people are Baptists
if people like I tell right now look you
know my mission I don't care if you're
Baptist Muslim if you worship dogs and
you watch your cat I don't gave you're
gay straight for Drupal kit whatever you
wanna be I'm not gonna tell you what to
be that's up to you all I want share
with you is how the love of a Jewish
carpenter changed my life if the shoe
fits where a man if not my issues yeah
you know what see us in that and to
impact people's lives to impact their
lives
so the hopefully they don't go through
what George Valdez went through and to
send books to prisoners so they can find
why why is the world in despair that
we're at because there's no hope man
yeah you've clearly experienced a lot in
your life and I think it's very good
that you're sharing it um I kind of want
to skip back real quick to the beginning
we just told the last half of it sort of
after you got out but I found it really
interesting in your story how you talked
about at the moment you got on the plane
from Cuba to go to Miami you were in an
emotional coma because you were so young
you didn't know what was going on you
were feeling pain for the first time in
your life
and you sort of didn't know what to do
you didn't know whether you should cry
whether you should be confident you
didn't know what to do you just kind of
went to the plain and emotionless you
know and it was I tell people it was
three cataclysmic events in my life that
was number one and first of all my
friends were very wealthy so we got
everything
so communism did not affect us at all
what I felt as a ten year old kid I had
a bicycle had all the toys I wanted we
had television in our house we had a
chauffer we went to the beach after
school so life was good for me so all of
a sudden I'm waking up at five o'clock
in the morning and my mother says get
dressed and I'm like we were going just
to Miami so I want to get to pack a
little suitcase of toys no no chose the
clothes on your back and I was very
confused I had no idea what was going on
and my mother was very religious it was
a period when we were go to school
infidel with teachers about communism
right your ten-year-old kid your
impression about everything right and
but we would come home and my mother
said that's all [ __ ] God God God God
that was everything for her right so her
whole thing is my kids are not going to
grow up in a communist country like they
cannot worship God freely so explain to
someone who doesn't understand the
history of communists communism and Cuba
and Fidel Castro's regime explain why
they were so against religion and
Christianity and all that you know if
you read some of her those books which I
was able to read when I went to Cuba and
it was really interesting because you
know it was raised by priests right
Fidel went to the best just four schools
in Cuba communist belief well let's go
back if if you read the writings of Karl
Marx right and Max hangul right the
Communist Manifesto
mm-hmm oh it's a perfect world right
everybody's the same everybody makes the
same nobody abuses anybody you know
there's no class distinction right and
so Fidel comes along and I tell people
ah do you think that Fidel was in
reality wanted to be a communist
I think Fidel came to United States
looking for help and they didn't they
turned his back so there was two
superpower he was smart enough to
realize that hey I go with one or the
other or maybe wiped out but the thing
about it is that in in the in the
communist ideology they teach you that
man is the center that there is no God
right that God and religion is an opiate
it's a drug used by institutions to
control people so the first thing that
they do in school were little was start
teachers through a program called the
Pioneers like the Boy Scouts and they
would teach you all this right and Fidel
the supreme leader's the best and all
that stuff I mean to me was so good you
thing is all what do you know right
exactly
but I come home and my mother's like my
my right if it was up to my dad he
would've never said nothing because my
dad was very rich life was good for him
and he wasn't gonna rock any boats but
not my mom and my mom was five feet I
tell me my mom went five five Osama bin
Laden would have had nothing on her
because she was a terrorist and she's
like no and I'm taking my kids out of
here and we're going to Miami now think
about that think about her conviction to
abandon a life of wealth to come to
United States with nothing forty years
of age three little kids
ten nine and five but at the airport
what happens is so as I'm going to the
to the airport with them I'm in sort of
a daze right nowadays because confus
what's going on why
maybe we're just going for a weekend you
know I have no idea about anything maybe
we don't need to pack anything if we're
just going to go and come back because
then you know they didn't tell me much
all they said is just packed we're going
to Miami and so we're waiting to board
the airplane and I see my were the last
people Valdez of course so I see my mom
crying and my dad is I'm not going and I
was like so my mom comes up to me and
grabs my hand and grab my brother's
sister and said George you go to Miami
I'll see you one day they made a mistake
and they said she couldn't come and my
dad of course didn't want to come along
anyway so he's like you ain't going I'm
going right so I'm like and
when I become in a daze that's when I
become comatose I'm walking through the
airplane and my world changed I went
from being a ten-year-old kid playing
with kites on the street baseball which
was my life to becoming a man-whore son
to be kind of father animal to my blood
sister and we come to Miami and my dad
got in the plainest were finally leaving
and we come to Miami and what we do 11
of us go live in a one-bedroom apartment
with one bathroom writing down what time
we're gonna piss cuz everyone had to go
to school work right so here we go from
how there was one square block to a
little 800 square foot apartment in
Little Havana
you know was it with 11 oz altogether
Wow and so my father you know went to
work as a janitor for J Byron's which is
like a JC Penney's and making minimum
wage 85 cents an hour and never complain
and I was like I was mad because a month
later we moved into all a house because
one thing that Cubans did that was
really great was you come to Miami and
you go live in somebody's house for free
for a month or two month or you can save
enough money to rent your own apartment
right and then you do the same for
somebody else right right and that's how
we helped each other you know that's how
we were overcome we were able to
overcome you know then you're getting
off the airplane and seeing signs that
said no animals no Cubans you see Havana
go back to Cuba speak English I'm
thinking so I'm like what the hell's
going on
I didn't see no distinction I didn't
realize that people hated people yeah so
anyway we go and uh and then we started
to go hungry mo or we would have for
breakfast was one glass of all this
powder milk from Vietnam that would not
mix with two raw eggs and that's all we
had the night time and night time we had
rice and beans and I remember finding
out a friend of mine was having lunch
and he had just come from Cuba a year
earlier than us and I come to find out
and I'm like I said that you can afford
lunch and you're like oh we get food
stamps really what the hell's that
said always this little thing that
government gives you with that we go to
the grocery store my food man I thought
I discovered the universe I go back to
my dad I said hey Dad remember I've been
telling you that my friend he has lunch
and he's like you know he was that type
of man that they speak much and I said
uh he told me that he gets food stamps
hey dad do you know about food stamps he
says uh yeah I do I said well why don't
we get food stamps
he says son that's for poor people I'm
like holy [ __ ]
we haven't gotten to poor yet we got to
dig our way out of whatever to stay
dizzy I climb up to pour and I said that
I'll be not poor he said no son we just
don't have any money and then I never
forget that
he took his two fingers put them in my
chest ain't says you get up early and
help feed your family I was ten I
weighed 70 pounds I was like skinny rail
and I'm like I've been getting up since
4:30 in the morning and I'm 64 now for
the last 54 years but we did and we
struggle and we survived you know and
and this is the thing that that as a lot
of time as I speak I talk about like how
we see in the world here what's
happening here in America you know with
the government giving you now all this
extra might now there's people in need
help yeah without a doubt
but another takes emulous Jackson's yeah
we the stimulus check with and now
people don't wanna go back to work
because they get more with a $600 and it
apparently did before and what they
don't realize what they don't realize is
that the government is creating the new
slavery of America the new slaves why
are we the slaves because what does the
slave the slave is you just sit back and
wait till the master to tell you
something because you never be creative
you never be enterpreneur you never know
you're gonna lose your work habits
you're a loser decide to succeed you
drive everything easy gonna sit back and
wait till the master send your check and
then what happens one day the master
don't send a check
[Laughter]